yeah shout out to meek has he reached
out to you
yeah he reached out to me before
you don't sound too excited about me
now you reached out to me before we
ain't going you know are you cool do you
try to sign you the dream chasers
yeah you can see that here you try to
sign you he sent somebody to try to sign
me
to dream chases here so he sent
something like someone to try to recruit
you yeah
why not um
why didn't he come himself boss i don't
know
you don't know so it was a no
had he came himself pause
would you would you have maybe given it
like more consideration yeah for sure
yeah yeah that's what's up shout out to
me i [ __ ] with me though no but i don't
know i don't i don't i ain't never won't
be the artist designer and even no other
artist any way though like i'm smarter
than my own [ __ ] you know yeah that's
smart
yeah do you have your own company now
yeah unless you started what's that
rare
it's just rare yeah it's your
entertainment right now but i might
switch it up
you've been changing i gotta get an
official name like they're really get
the chain with the logo
[Music]